people were
feeling intimidated and
and
threatened disruptive harassing behavior
from some members of the self-proclaimed
freedom convoy forced the shutdown of
four happy goat cafe locations in ottawa
during what should have been a much
needed opportunity to reopen after
lockdown somebody's got to stand up and
say enough is enough
owner henry assad and a group of private
citizens did something that's never been
done before in canada they won a court
order to freeze crypto assets of convoy
organizers the lawsuit includes the 21
year old ottawa resident who won an
injunction banning incessant deafening
horn honking earlier this month
[Music]
the unprecedented mareva injunction
takes aim at nine digital asset
platforms to freeze and disclose
information about funds sent to convoy
protesters shattering the myth that
bitcoin and cryptocurrencies like it
aren't trackable the common argument was
bitcoin is just for terrorists because
it's easily obfuscated and they can hide
behind the scenes but each and every
bitcoin transaction is recorded on a
blockchain a digital ledger that
provides a time stamped record
information including amounts and
digital wallets are there for anyone
with the right tools to see identities
can be hidden behind one or several
wallets but the digital tracks are there
and authorities can catch up to users
when they exchange crypto into canadian
dollars or other conventional currency
crypto exchange bit by is named in the
court order and says it's ready to
comply though its anti-money laundering
executive says there's something much
more pervasive and much more difficult
to track
if we want to talk about evil tools
cash like i mean cash is the most
anonymous thing in the world
regardless of how it's done financial
experts say it's imperative to get at
the cash flow lifeblood of the movement
which has seen millions in pledges
including from extremist political
factions around the world you cut off
the money you cut off the ability to
protest to sustain itself failing to do
so means the anti-vax convoy can regroup
again and again ann gaviola global news
toronto